wir sind hier nicht sicher deswegen
sollten wir schnell weg das wasser
steigt flutet unsere häuser zehn minuten
dauert die überfahrt vom festland nach
cádiz die kleine insel versinkt in der
karibik stück für stück die population
wächst immer weiter bald sind wir schon
2000 menschen wir haben einfach kein
platz mehr um neue häuser zu bauen
wir sehen zu wie das wasser steigt es
überflutet die häuser jedes jahr wird es
schlimmer
die lokale regierung müsse jetzt handeln
um den menschen schnellstmöglich einen
sicheren ort zum leben zu ermöglichen
ich bereite alles so weit vor damit wir
aufs land ziehen können
wir brauchen einen neuen ort mit
genügend platz und besseren
lebensbedingungen
denn die westliche welt nicht bald
drastisch einlenkt und wirkungsvolle
maßnahmen zur co2 reduzierung umsetzt
wird gar die subgroup nicht die letzte
insel sein die im meer verschwindet
[Musik]